[Music]
if you've ever picked up a book and
found it's full of surreal plants
unknown diagrams zodiac rings and a
language which is completely
undecipherable you're likely looking at
a copy of the voynich manuscript the
book that nobody can translate this
medieval text which has been dated to
the early 15th century is one of the
most mysterious books ever written as
even after hundreds of years no one has
been able to definitively decode it so
for this entry into the archive we'll
take a look at this bizarre book and see
what we can learn about its history and
possible meaning the name of the
manuscript comes from wilford voynich a
polish book collector with very cool
spectacles who first discovered the book
at a college in italy in 1912. he was
understandably baffled by the bizarre
language in images within and countless
experts have been trying to make sense
of it ever since today the original copy
is stored at the beinecke rare book and
manuscript library at yale university if
you were to open the manuscript you'd
find that the first section of the
mysterious text is dedicated almost
entirely to plants most of these bizarre
flora aren't ones you'd ever find in
nature and instead seem either
completely made up or impossible hybrids
of existing plants with the roots of one
species attached to the stem of another
with the flowers of a third for good
measure only a few drawings can actually
be matched with real plant species
namely the wild pansy and a variation of
maidenhair fern but that's about all
we've got but it's not just the plant
drawings within the manuscript that are
mysterious there are also strange cosmic
wheels and astrological symbols
decorating many of the pages some of
them with stylized suns or stars these
diagrams seem related to astrology or
zodiac constellations although many of
them don't match up with familiar models
astrology did play a role in plant
gathering and medical procedures during
the period in which the manuscript was
likely written so that could be the
connection to the first section of the
book but it's hard to deduce much beyond
that aside from some pretty weird art of
people bathing in giant tubs i'm just
gonna skip over the third section of the
book has some art of what might be
alchemical equipment but as is the case
with the zodiac wheels a lot of the art
really has very little resemblance to
common alchemical equipment and symbols
of the time so what's going on here well
with most other books you just read the
words and figure out what's supposed to
be going on but that's easier said than
done with the voynich manuscript the
script is written in is completely
unknown indeed there are some theories
that that's because it's been put
through an advanced cipher or code by
the original author scrambled up to a
degree which makes it difficult to
unravel a lot of effort has been
expended to try and crack it including
some promising recent work with ai but
despite decades of trying most experts
agree the majority of the book remains
unreadable aside from a secret code it's
also possible the strange alphabet is an
attempt to write down some spoken
dialect that had no established writing
system if this is the case the alphabet
is completely unique and therefore
almost impossible to decipher another
distinct possibility however is that the
book is filled with nonsense the text
has no meaning and was designed to mess
with people but we'll come back to that
concept in a moment before we completely
give up if we can't understand the
images or the language do we at least
have some idea where it came from well
once again there are a lot of unknowns
there's a letter from the 16th century
which suggests it was once owned by holy
roman emperor rudolf ii and was then
passed on to his personal doctor jacobus
synapsis then to antique collector
george barrish then to a bohemian doctor
jan merrick marcy then perhaps to the
scholar thanos kercher then maybe to
priest peter jan bax who placed it in
the collection where voynich finally
purchased it basically the book's been
all over as for who the original author
was among all this mass some have
theorized it might have been 13th
century friar roger bacon or 15th
century italian engineer giovanni
fontana who created some surreal artwork
which does look somewhat similar others
have theorized that the whole thing is a
more modern hoax and was possibly even
fabricated by vuenich himself recent
radiocarbon dating of the parchment
however more or less rules this
possibility out as old tests have
indicated the book is almost certainly
from at least the early 15th century so
at least in that respect the manuscript
is authentic but regardless of who the
author is perhaps the most important
question is why why write this at all
it's possible that this is a genuine
medical text just written in a dialect
we can't read or it's possible it's
something even stranger but it's also
not impossible the whole purpose of this
book was to frustrate future generations
even if the manuscript isn't a modern
hoax that doesn't rule out the
possibility it's the medieval era
equivalent of a prank we sometimes think
of past societies as perpetually serious
but medieval art is often ridiculous and
seems designed to confound so it's a
distinct possibility the voynich
manuscript was made for a similar
purpose and maybe the real author is
just laughing at us from the beyond in
any case it's a fascinating and
mysterious book there's additional
research that has been done over the
years and i'd encourage you to delve in
further if you're interested and as
always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry into the archive
please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
[Music]